Thank You Hana thanks to all of you for
coming my name is Jonathan friedland I'm
going to be guiding the proceedings this
evening and often you know you have
these cultural combat evenings where the
debate is of course enlightening and
fascinating but rarely can it claim to
be urgently topical and yet somehow with
two novels one written in 1931 and one
written in between 1948 1949 you
nevertheless have two works that speak
to us in our own time with great urgency
and topicality we of course are going to
leave proceedings tonight knowing which
one does that more than the other one
but that is the subject before so two
dominant novels of the 20th century
discussed and debated and advocated by
two of the leading public intellectuals
of our 21st century so it's going to be
a hugely stimulating evening the other
thing about cultural combat events is
that they often have a different quality
from the debates that intelligent
squared
hosts on this stage those of course are
about the current affairs questions of
our time the big political questions
whereas the cultural debate can be at a
more serene pace and yet here we have
two novels which speak absolutely of the
questions that ordinarily we might be
discussing in an evening of political
debate two novels that deal in tyranny
in technology in memory in conflict in
love the big questions of our time
discussed by and aired by two of the
great writers of the last century as I
said so the debate could not be more
dramatically poised between these two
great novels and I'm going to present to
you the two people who will be making
the case for each of them along with
a starry cast of ancillary auxilary
backup and defense for their argument
let me hand introduce our two speakers
to make these arguments for advocating
for Aldous Huxley's brave new world is
the widely acclaimed novelist
broadcaster political commentator and
literary critic his most recent novels
are umbrella shark and phone a trilogy
which the New Statesman predicted will
become and I quote one of the most
significant literary works of our
century books the reflect and refract
the hideousness of our times making the
case for brave new world is will self
[Applause]
and to advocate for George Orwell's 1984
is a staff writer on The New Yorker of
some time and award-winning author
essayist lecturer and broadcaster he
wrote after Donald Trump's first week in
office in The New Yorker about quote how
primitive atavistic and uncomplicated ly
brutal Trump's brand of authoritarianism
is turning out to be we have to go back
to 1984 he wrote because in effect we
have to go back to 1948 to get the
flavor he is Adam Gopnik
[Applause]
and as I said bringing in reinforcements
for both our two advocates as if you
like expert witnesses are actors of
great distinction who will bring to life
the written word on the page here
tonight on our stage please welcome
first the rising star of film and
television who starred as Miss Havisham
in the BBC series series Dickensian and
as the Russian princess lenka Regina in
the recent BBC adaptation of war and
peace or warm welcome for tuppence
Middleton best known for playing louis
xiv in the recent TV series versailles
he's also starred in the oscar-winning
film adaptation of lai miserable and the
series vikings and will appear in the
forthcoming series on Netflix
of Black Mirror he is George Blagdon
[Applause]
an actor known for his work at the Royal
Shakespeare Company and his roles in TV
and film have included the West Wing
the IT Crowd motherland' mr. Selfridge
Hamlet Bobby and Sleepy Hollow
he is Orlando Seal
[Applause]
and completing our lineup we're
delighted to say that joining us is one
of the country's most celebrated stage
and screen actors best with what a best
loved perhaps performance in films such
as Four Weddings and a funeral a room
with a view and Shakespearean love he
has also written biographies of to great
acclaim on Oscar Wilde Orson Welles
Charles Dickens and Richard Wagner he is
of course Simon Callow so before we get
fully underway and we get legal with the
two advocates making the case in this
courtroom that we've assembled here just
an opening question to each of you let's
start with you
Adam Gopnik a Gavin got Nick and what
drew you first to the man whose work you
are advocating tonight George Orwell I
read Orwell for the first time when I
was 12 or 13 growing up in Canada and I
read 1984 and the descriptions of wine
and sex in 1984 were hugely impressive
to me as a 12 year old a key I think
that there's a humane subtext in Orwell
that transcends even the inhumane
material and so you the same question
will self what drew you first if you
remember that we all first encounter
with Aldous Huxley my childhood would
took place Jonathan in antique hay and
chrome yellow until I reached
adolescence I was eyeless in Gaza
there's a brave new world once my balls
drop what can I tell you I drank in
Huxley with my mother's milk it's an
element I swim in I hope you there by
setting the tone for the rest of the
evening
very nicely done and if you can keep up
with that then you're doing very well
for the rest of the evening we want you
to stay in that genre excellent so let's
get on with the proceedings as you know
on your way in that this evening you
will have
in for a pre vote to get a sense of your
opinion and we are going to tell you the
outcome of that only after you've heard
the cases made so the purpose of this
evening is really for you to put aside
the preconceptions and prejudices you
may have walked in with and instead
listen to the arguments as they're made
and see if you can be moved either from
the Huxley column into the Orwell column
or vice versa
or and I think all the prized
constituency this evening if you were a
don't know before these two gentlemen
here want to move you onto their side so
first to make his case is with I think
25 minutes I'm going to hold you
strictly to time there may be an implied
ping of the glass from me but here to
make his case is will self
[Applause]
yes have you left your prejudices behind
that's what I wonder and I also would
have liked you all to only have voted if
you have indeed read both novels in
their entirety and hopefully fairly
recently I want to make a few
preliminary remarks because remarks at
the beginning are always preliminary the
status of all well in our culture is
such that he's earned the epithet sin
George and I doubt that very very few
people entered the Emanuel Center this
evening with a preconception about
Aldous Huxley a strong idea about who he
was and what he represented but it's
almost impossible to be an adult in this
country without having a very very firm
view about all well and I need to
deconstruct your image of all well a bit
before I even get to the business of
brave new world because I have a
suspicion that many of you will be
naturally prejudiced in all wells favor
fair enough I bow to no man or woman
when it comes to admiration for George
Orwell he was an extremely fine writer
journalist and broadcaster you may be
aware that a statue of him is being
installed in the courtyard of new
Broadcasting House almost as we speak I
think people on the right in Britain
love George Orwell because they see him
as something of a socialist turncoat who
virtually on his deathbed sent in a list
of some 500 fellow travelers who he
believed might be sympathetic to the
Soviet cause so that's earned him the
lasting love
people on the right who always pull him
up as an example of the kind of good
lefty who knew where to draw the line
and of course people on the left laughs
and George because he was an old Etonian
who went and lived down an hour in Paris
wrote an anti-imperialist novel and
cleaved to a kind of English
traditionalism that you see written
everywhere in 1984 and if I can launch a
preemptive strike against Adam Gopnik
isn't it notable how much variance ed it
himself when he said he liked the sex
and the boozing in 1984 the bits in 1984
that are really good are the bits about
1948 and it's to all wells credit that
he simply reversed the numerals in order
to title his novel fair enough
I bow as I say to know man when it comes
to admiration for all well and indeed
I've been to barn Hill where he wrote
1984 in fact I wrote myself on the
island of Jura for three months purely
in order to channel the influence of
George Orwell however when it comes to
actually being prescient about the state
we're in now I'm afraid 1984 is not a
terribly good guide you have to ask
yourself the simple reversal of the
numerals 1948 turned into 1984 all works
of fictional prognostication we know
it's a truism
it's a PAP ulam are really about their
own error so I ask you as an initial
question is 2017 more like 1948 in other
words are we a society recovering from a
world war in which we face the prospect
of another world war or at any rate some
sort of deadlock between massive empires
or are we
in a condition as a country perhaps more
akin to 1931 the years immediately after
the stock market crash when you saw very
much the same kind of pattern of debt
privation in Britain that you're seeing
now in 2017 with a kind of isolated and
perhaps still relatively well-off group
in the southeast of the country and
considerable poverty and deprivation
elsewhere so let me just Park that with
you dear audience and the other thing I
want to call your attention to having
blown away the sfumato of you're all
well worship I hope that's now gone okay
it's to say to you audience I always
think with an audience you can always
address its highest common denominator
or its lowest common denominator you can
either make fart jokes and allude to
things that juvenile people find funny
or you can try and hit the highest
common denominator and make some serious
and important arguments well judging
from the ticket price for this event a
subject I will return to later judging
from its location judging from your
marvelously swanee a appearance this
evening I think it's probably best to go
for the highest common denominator
because I suspect that you are all
alphas and it at worst beta pluses I
don't think there are many epsilon semi
morons in the audience tonight
at all so tell me alphas of London are
you suffering a life of constant
deprivation at the moment only drinking
bathtub gin that's
tinks and trying to light cigarettes
where the tobacco's so dry that they
fall out of them as we raise them to
your lips or are your lives in fact
characterized by instant gratification
usually by consumption of one sort or
another hold that thought while these
marvelous actors give us our first
extract from the sublime brave new world
[Applause]
observe said the director triumphantly
observe books and loud noises flowers
and electric shocks already in the
infant mind these couples are
compromising ly linked and after 200
repetitions of the same or a similar
lesson we'll be wedded indissolubly what
man has joined nature is powerless to
put asunder they all grow up with what
the psychologists used to call an
instinctive hatred of books and flowers
reflexes unalterably conditioned they'll
be safe from books and botany all their
lives one of the students held up his
hand though I can see quite well why you
can't have lower caste people wasting
the community's time over books and that
there is always the risk of their
reading something which might
undesirably decondition one of their
reflexes yep well I can't understand
about the flowers why go to the trouble
of making it psychologically impossible
for deltas to like flowers patiently the
DHC explained if the children were made
to scream at the sight of a rose that
was on grounds of high economic policy
not so very long ago a century or there
abouts Gama's Delta's even Epsilon's had
been conditioned
like flowers flowers in particular and
wild nature in general the idea was to
make them want to be going out into the
country at every available opportunity
and so compelled them to consume
transport and didn't they consume
transport ask the student quite a lot
the THC replied but nothing else
promises primroses and landscapes have
one grave defect they are gratuitous a
love of nature keeps no factories busy
it was decided to abolish the love of
nature
at any rate among the lower classes to
abolish the love of nature but not the
tendency to consume transport because it
was essential that they should keep on
going to the country even though they
hated it the problem was to find an
economically sound a reason for
consuming transport than a mere
affection for primroses and landscapes
it was duly found we conditioned the
masses to hate the country concluded the
director simultaneously we conditioned
them to love all country sports at the
same time we see to it that all
countries sports shall entail the use of
elaborate apparatus so that they consume
manufactured articles as well as
transport hence those electric shocks I
see said the student and was silent lost
in admiration
[Applause]
I hope everybody's got their phone on
Airport or whatever it is mode because
if you didn't have it on airport mode
you might receive a little electric
shock during the event yeah so recent
studies in cognitive science establish
that you get a little jolt of dopamine
every time you get an alert on your
mobile phone every time you push a
button on it or a consumer or a computer
console you are rewarded there is a
pleasurable sensation
you will have noticed in the flow of
your screen mediated lives that there
are a myriad of these little electric
shocks going on throughout your day the
only difference between you and the
children in brave new world who are
conditioned to hate flowers and
beautiful things and books in that way
is that your conditioning is happening
while you're wide awake or are you is
the current lifestyle of the consumer in
fact a kind of waking dream what Huxley
understands only too well is conditions
under what we might call late capitalism
in other words the kind of neoliberal
capitalist societies we live in now what
Huxley understood only too well was that
in an economy that is defined by
consumption and advertising is the form
of behavioral conditioning everybody
will be perfectly Pacific as long as
their needs and their wants are
conflated in their own minds that is
very much the world we're living in you
don't need to be a Marxist to understand
that you're a commodity fetter
just you don't need to feel that you've
been conditioned to be conditioned I
think that's the real genius of the
dystopic future that Huxley summons up
in brave new world
there's no strife there's no angst the
only angst has to be introduced by an
agonist in the form of the Savage who
comes from outside the perfect and
hermetic world of the one state all
Wells dystopic future is so clearly
based on the command economy of the
Soviet Union there's no real reference
to production or how things are made
but in Huxley's world the combination
it's true that what he looked for in
terms of technological advance was most
clearly in the biological sciences but
think about it the conjunction in brave
new world of large-scale genetic
engineering and assembly line production
equals the automation that is currently
making most of the people in this Hall
tonight effectively unemployed in that
we do not actually contribute to our own
necessities we do really useless jobs
none more useless than Adam and me all
well didn't grasp any of that Orwell
didn't purpose his dystopia in mind of
the economic realities his was a
political attack a deliberate political
attack but Huxley understood the real
economic terms of existence under lay
capitalism and Huxley had the vision
because he understood that the key
determinant of the nature of the future
would be humankind's ongoing
relationship with technology to fashion
a portrait of a dystopic future where
while not exactly like the world we're
living in has so many of the same
lineaments it's uncanny let's have the
second extract how much I love you
Lenina he brought out almost desperately
an emblem of the inner tide of startled
elation the blood rushed up into
Leninist cheeks do you mean it John but
I hadn't mean to say so cried the savage
clasping his hands in the kind of agony
not until listen Lenina in Mal peace
people get married get what the
irritation had begun to creep back into
her voice what was he talking about now
for always they make a promise to live
together for always what a horrible idea
Lenina was genuinely shocked
outliving beauty's outward with a mind
that does renew swifter than blood
decays what it's like that in
Shakespeare too if thou dost break her
virgin not before all sanctimonious
ceremonies may with full and holy right
affords st. John talks sense I can't
understand a word you say
if I didn't like you so much I'd be
furious with you and suddenly her arms
were round his neck he felt her lips
soft against his own so deliciously soft
so warm and electric that inevitably he
found himself thinking of the embraces
in three weeks in a helicopter
oh the stereoscopic blonde and ah the
more the real black amor horah horah
horah he tried to disengage himself but
Lenina tightened her embrace if you
loved me why didn't you say so she
whispered drawing back her face to look
at him her eyes were tenderly
reproachful the murkiest Sten at the
most opportune place the voice of
conscience
poetically the strongest suggestion our
worser genius can shall never melt mine
honor into lust never never he resolved
you silly boy she was saying I wanted
you so much and if you wanted me to why
didn't you
but Lenina he began protesting and as
she immediately unwind her arms as she
stepped away from him he thought for a
moment that she had taken his unspoken
hint but when she unbuckled her white
patent cartridge belt and hung it
carefully over the back of a chair he
began to suspect that he had been
mistaken 'no Nina
he repeated apprehensively she put her
hand to her neck and gave a long
vertical pull her white sailors blouse
was ripped to the hem suspicion
condensed into a to too solid certainty
Nina what are you doing zip zip her
answer was wordless she stepped out of
her bell-bottom trousers her zippy cam
enix were a pale shell pink the arts
community songsters golden tea dangled
at her breast for those milk taps that
through the window bars poor men's eyes
the singing thundering magical words
made her seem doubly dangerous doubly
alluring soft soft but how piercing
boring and drilling into reason
tunneling through resolution the
strongest oaths are straw to the fire in
the blood be more abstemious all or else
zip the rounded pinkness fell apart like
a neatly divided apple a wriggle of the
arms a lifting first of the right foot
than the left the zippy cam Enix were
lying lifeless and as though deflated on
the floor still wearing her shoes and
socks and a rakish Lee tilted round
white cap she advanced towards him
darling darling if only you'd said so
before she held out her arms
but instead of also saying darling and
holding out his arms the savage
retreated in terror flapping his hands
at her as though he were trying to scare
away some intruding and dangerous animal
for backward escapes and he was brought
to Bay against the wall
sweet said La Nina and laying her hands
on his shoulders pressed herself against
him put your arms around me she
commanded hug me till you drugged me
honey she too had poetry at her command
new words that sang and were spells and
beat drums kiss me she closed her eyes
she let her voice sink to a sleepy man
kiss me till I'm in a coma
hug me honey's snuggly the savage caught
her by the wrists tore her hands from
his shoulders and thrust her roughly
away at arm's length
[Applause]
well it may be cast in a different light
it may be focused in this scene in the
form of the savage John's rejection of
Lenina
who is a kind of properly promiscuous
member of the one state whereas he is
stuck in this antediluvian mindset where
he believes in fidelity and monogamy and
you may well be sitting there thinking
really how can this be a picture of the
kind of sexual politics and reality of
our own era but I think it is I really
think it is just consider Huxley was
writing in 1931 before the contraceptive
pill but he anticipates its role in the
one state there's nothing like it of
course in 1984 Huxley anticipates of
course genetic engineering something
that we now have something incidentally
that's keeping me alive since I take
medication that kills stem cells so I'm
well aware of the existence of that and
you may think the idea that Huxley puts
into a brave new world whereby in the
one state it's mandatory to be
promiscuous it's mandatory to share
yourself with other people sexually
doesn't really apply to the world we're
in you may particularly feel it doesn't
apply to you for example if you're
sexually frustrated right now but the
fact of the matter is you can get that
little electronic shock device that you
have in your pocket out and you can
switch it off air airplane mode and
within milliseconds you can be looking
at a variety and intensity of
pornography the world has never seen the
like of the quantity of pornographic
imagery on the world wide web is simply
phenomenal
again back to cognitive science I'm
going to talk a bit more after the next
extract about the two visions of war and
peace in 1984 in brave new world in
brave new world permanent peace in 1984
permanent war but what's significant
here is that research shows the people
who are watching internet pornography or
engaging in internet pornography are
experiencing at the level of brain
chemistry the same thing as people who
are actually having sex
so our indulgence and I'm sure you're
sitting there thinking it doesn't apply
to me I never look at pornography but
nonetheless you sense it's great
seething Polya lating morass behind the
screen you know it's there and that is a
kind of mass collective promiscuity but
even so you know in the years since 1931
we have gone into a much much more
promiscuous much better it's serial
monogamy or actual polygamy of one form
or another we do live in an increasingly
Singleton society the number of single
households goes up and up and up and
again this is something that we don't
really see anything of in 1984 because
apart from helicopters speakwrite
machines and the ubiquitous screens in
1984 there is no illusion to technology
whatsoever back to the genetic
engineering of the different groups in
1984 or there in brave new world all the
different classes are you alphas so
confident you're not living in a world
that actually does have deltas and
epsilon semi morons stick around after
the event and have a chat with some of
the people who are cleaning this hall
before you go home people who are
probably
going back to zone for people who may
well be in the black or gray economy or
certainly on minimum wage they're among
us the Epsilon's and Delta's of brave
new world but the thing about us alphas
is we've always got the feel ease and
the stereoscopic movies we've always got
a virtual reality to hand usually right
in our pocket in order to evade our
realization of that it's not an enviable
task telling an audience that they're
living in a dystopia it's a dirty job
somebody has to do it here's the third
extract
but God's the reason for everything
Noble and fine and heroic if you had a
God my dear young friend said Mustapha
Mond
civilization has absolutely no need of
nobility or heroism these things are
symptoms of political inefficiency in a
properly organized society like ours
nobody has any opportunities for being
Noble or heroic conditions have got to
be thoroughly unstable before the
occasion can arise where there are walls
where there are divided allegiances
where there are temptations to be
resisted objects of love to be fought
for or defended there have some sense
but there aren't any wars nowadays the
greatest care is taken to prevent you
from loving anyone too much there's no
such thing as a divided Allegiance
you're so conditioned that you can't
help doing what you want to do and what
you want to do is on the whole so
pleasant so many of the natural impulses
are allowed free play that there really
aren't any temptations to resist and if
ever by some unlucky chance anything
unpleasant should somehow happen why
there's always so much to give you a
holiday from the facts there's always
soup to calm your anger to reconcile you
to your enemies to make you patient
long-suffering in the past you could
only accomplish these things by making a
great effort and after years of hard
moral training now you swallow two or
three half gram tablets and there you
are anybody can be virtuous now you can
carry at least half your morality about
in a bottle Christianity without tears
that's what soma is
but the tears are necessary don't you
remember what a fellow said if after
every tempest came such calms may the
winds blow till they have weakened death
there's a story one of the old Indians
used to tell us about the girl of
Metesky
the young men who wanted to marry her
had to do a morning's hoeing in her
garden it seemed easy but there were
flies and mosquitoes magic ones most of
the young men simply couldn't stand the
biting and stinging but the one that
could he got the girl charming but in
civilized countries said the controller
you can have girls without hoeing for
them and there aren't any flies or
mosquitoes - Stingo we got rid of them
all centuries ago the Savage nodded
frowning you got rid of them yes that's
just like you getting rid of everything
unpleasant instead of learning to put up
with it whether tis better in the mind
to suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune or to take arms
against a sea of troubles and by
opposing end them but you don't do
either neither suffer nor oppose you
just abolish the slings and arrows it's
too easy what you need the savage went
on is something with Tears for a change
nothing costs enough here exposing what
is mortal and then Shaw to all that
fortune death and danger dare even for
an eggshell isn't there something in
that he asked looking up at Mustapha
Mond quite apart from God though of
course God would be a reason for it
isn't there something in living
dangerously
[Applause]
I've got to be quick we're under the gun
you're all on soma or quite a lot of you
are 11 million prescriptions for
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
written in the last year in the UK
statistically at least 10% of this
audience is on some kind of mood
altering drugs as I speak to you
Orwell didn't spot that one coming
Aldous did and not just things like
prozac and sock sack but the oxycontin
plague epidemic in America at the moment
coming soon to a doctor's surgery near
you
prozac to get it up zop Lacan to make it
lie down again
I shouldn't imagine there's actually
anybody in this room that hasn't got
some chemical in their system at the
moment antibiotics they're a form of
soma - really they are you live your
lives in a kind of amniotic fluid of
drugs Orwell didn't see that he's just
got his lousy victory gin but Huxley
understood the technology is imminent in
human being and that it determines the
historical ear as we live through
permanent war versus no war some might
like to argue that we are still in an
extended version of superpower conflict
of some kind or another or certainly
that the idea of permanent peace is
ridiculous when we look at the mayhem
all around us in the world but get this
where you alphas are sitting right now
it's permanent peace none of you have
seen the least conflict in your
lifetimes if you've been sitting here in
zone one and two conflict goes on
somewhere else you watch it on your
stereoscopic movies or your Feelies and
your brain chemistry if you're an
aggressive young man makes you
effectively experience the same thing as
if you had inflicted violence Huxley
understood that this was the brave new
world
that was coming a world in which young
men sitting upstairs bedrooms pretending
to kill and slaughter thousands or a
world in which five million people have
died in the Congo in the last 15 or 20
years so you can have that mobile phone
in your pocket with its coltan in it war
for us nowadays is a spectacle that
takes place in another country since
9/11 what maybe half a million people
have died in the Middle East five
million people have been displaced
failed states in Iraq Syria the Lebanon
Yemen but it's really peaceful here in
our newfound land isn't it that conflict
doesn't really disturb our sense of
civic peace it's something going on it's
noises off for us again
I think Huxley understood that kind of
world
he understood how a world of consumption
and conditioning and advertising could
insulate people from the reality and the
real terms of their existence I urge you
I urge you to give brave new world your
vote thank you thank you
so tropic world as well you've got the
bit about killing all the Flies okay we
got good
so in this combat in the language of
sports we'll self has taken it to the
opposition they're sticking it to 1984
making the case that Aldous Huxley in
brave new world anticipates the world we
live in today like capitalism
consumerism antidepressants genetic
engineering pornography and says 1984 is
just a political screed against
soviet-style communism so the challenge
is lay down here to pick it up and make
the opposing case for 1984 Adam Gopnik
thank you thank you ladies and gentlemen
thank you will thank you players will I
too was once a Huxley in I too once
thought that Huxley's vision was the one
that was dominant that would indeed be
triumphant in our time as recently as
the turn of the millennium I think most
of us felt that way it seemed that we
had entered into a realm in which some
of you may recall this history had ended
in which a model of materialist pleasure
in which the blind pursuit of
technological progress was all that
would preoccupy mankind it might have
been even a time when the thing that
most preoccupied us was the possibility
that there would be wildly erotic women
who failed to rise to our standards of
Shakespearean drama but that is not the
time we live in now not the time we live
in now at all in the last few years in
the last decade in the last five years
and certainly for those of us who live
in America in the past year we've become
aware of the ongoing cogent see and
necessity of Orwell's vision the two
visions we're looking at tonight can be
I think simply encapsulated Huxley
showed us a vision of the future in
which we would enslave ourselves through
the blind pursuit of pleasure and Orwell
showed us a vision of the world
which we would be enslaved by those in
blind pursuit of power and I asked you
if the history of recent times doesn't
suggest more powerfully than that second
darker vision is not now in the
ascendancy shockingly in the ascendancy
startlingly perhaps in the ascendancy
but with Putin and Russia with the waves
of right-wing nationalism running
through Europe and yes above all with
the rise of Trump ISM in America we see
the brute realities of Orwell's vision
of power forget for a moment all the
parts of 1984 that are indeed is will
rightly said taken from Britain in 1948
the bad meat and the bad bread of the
BBC cafeteria see past that for a moment
see past Orwell's attempt to allegorize
Soviet Union in Stalinism and spread it
into the future that's not the core of
Orwell's vision that's not what makes
1984 matter now know what Orwell saw was
that there would be three principal ways
in which power would propagate itself
and enslave free men and women first
through the corruption of thought
through the compression of language not
merely by reducing the means of argument
not merely by reducing things that there
are to argue about as we find in
Huxley's homogenized and sedated
pleasure satiated world nope Orwell saw
that we could make it impossible for
rational speech to be heard at all for
language and argument to take place
simply by altering the means with which
we communicate second Orwell saw that
power would be able to propagate and
extend itself through the perpetual
creation of an evil other it didn't even
matter what the other was first we were
always at war with Eastasia
and then always at war with Eurasia at
any moment another has to be created
that can become a focus of hatred and
blind us to the realities
power and the state and third and
finally Orwell anticipated far more
cogently even than he projected forward
the ideology of the Soviet state in the
future Orwell anticipated the
possibility of an autocracy of a form of
totalitarianism that had no connection
at all to any utopian vision Marxist or
materialist whatever no relation at all
to a positive vision of the future
however distorted or warped it might
have become no Orwell saw that the evil
of the future would be an evil that
would be rooted in an appetite for power
and a desire to perpetuate power in the
hands of a small inner party of an
oligarchy if you like of a kleptocracy
if you like whose only end was simply to
perpetually gain more power and inflict
more pain to keep it I want you to think
about those three central pillars of
Orwell's vision when you consider which
book to turn to tonight the first one
the question of language and thought
Orwell's great preoccupation how it is
that simply by altering the means the
instrument of language with which we
must articulate our vision of the world
and our argument for Liberty by altering
language we can reshape thought here's
the first instance of that as Orwell
pictures it in an exchange in the
cafeteria
it's a beautiful thing the destruction
of words of course the great wastage is
in the verbs and adjectives there are
hundreds of nouns that could be got rid
of as well it's isn't only the synonyms
they're also the antonyms after what
justification is there for a word which
is simply the opposite of some other
word a word contains its opposite in
itself take good for instance if you
have a word like good what need is there
for a word like bad ungood will do just
as well better because an exact opposite
which the other is not or again if you
want a stronger version of good what
sense is there and having a whole string
of vague useless words like excellent
and splendid and all the rest of them
plus good covers the meaning or
double-plus good if you want something
stronger still of course we use those
forms already but in the final version
of Newspeak there'll be nothing else in
the end the whole notion of goodness and
badness were covered by only six words
in reality only one word don't you see
the beauty it was Big Brother's idea
originally of course he added as an
afterthought a sort of vapid eagerness
flitted across Winston's face at the
mention of Big Brother nevertheless Syme
immediately detected a certain lack of
enthusiasm you haven't a real
appreciation of Newspeak Winston he said
almost sadly even when you write it
you're still thinking in Oh speak I've
read some of those pieces that you write
it in The Times occasionally but their
translations in your heart you'd prefer
to stick to old speak with all its
vagueness useless shades of meaning you
don't grasp the beauty of the
destruction of words here that new speak
is the only language in the world whose
vocabulary gets smaller every year
Winston did know that of course he
smiled sympathetically he hoped not
trusting himself to speak Syme bit off
another fragment of the dark-colored
bread chewed it briefly and went on
don't you see that the whole aim of
Newspeak is to narrow the range of
thought in the end which will make
thoughtcrime
literally impossible because there will
be no words in which to express it every
concept that can ever be needed will be
expressed by exactly one word with its
meaning rigidly defined and all its
subsidiary meanings rubbed out and
forgotten already in the 11th edition
we're not far from that point the
process will still be continuing long
after you and I are dead every year
fewer and fewer words and the range of
consciousness even now of course there's
no reason or excuse for committing
thoughtcrime it's merely a question of
self discipline reality control but in
the end there won't be any need even for
that the revolutions will be complete
when the language is perfect Newsweek is
in shock an ink sock is Newsweek he
added with a sort of mystical
satisfaction they recurred to Winston
that by the year 2050 at the very latest
not a single human being will be alive
who could understand such a conversation
as we are having now accept began
Winston doubtfully and he stopped it had
been on the tip of his tongue to say
except the proles
but he checked himself not feeling fully
certain that this remark was not in some
way unorthodox Syme however had divined
what he was about to say the pros are
not human beings
he said carelessly
by 2050 earlier probably all real
knowledge of old speak would have
disappeared the whole literature of the
past would have been destroyed Chaucer
Shakespeare Milton Byron that only
exists in new speak versions not merely
changed into something different but
actually changed into something
contradictory of what they used to be
even the literature of the party will
change even the slogans will change how
can you have a slogan like freedom is
slavery when the concept of freedom has
been abolished the whole climate of
thought will be different in fact there
will be no sport as we understand it now
orthodoxy means not thinking not needing
to think orthodoxy is unconsciousness
[Applause]
Oh orthodoxy is unconsciousness the end
of Newspeak is to deprive us of the
possibility of argument not merely to
out argue us but to deprive us of that
possibility
now Orwell made one error looking into
the future perhaps he thought that that
act of fatal compression would happen
through the elimination of lexical
elements of words isn't what we've seen
precisely is it what we've seen is that
you can achieve the same power of
thought control of the compression of
language and with it the elimination of
argument through the compression of
speech we live in an age of social media
in Twitter in which we've seen in the
most frightening possible way that the
only people who can manipulate those
means effectively are those with an
autocratic or an authoritarian vision
you may have heard of a leading
politician in the country from which I
flew last night who uses Twitter
exclusively as his means of
communication exactly because in the
limited number of characters that are
allowed to the speaker of Twitter our
own news speak it's impossible to have
what's essential to liberal democracy a
developed argument first this premise
and then this evidence and then this
revision know all you can do is make
authoritarian assertion and all you can
do in return is make a counter assertion
and in the act of making that counter
assertion you yourself subscribe
necessarily to the nature of
authoritarian discourse there's no way
you can have an extended reasoned
argument on Twitter you can merely have
a shouting match that's exactly what or
well understood about the way that the
corruption of language leads to the
impossibility of real political argument
the second thing that are well
understood and that he projects forward
to us through past all of the specific
details of 1984 the second thing he
understood was the power of hatred and
more subtly even more potently the way
that the power of hatred depends on the
manipulation of memory we always have to
have another - hey
whether it's East Asia Eurasia Islam the
bad hombre is coming across from Mexico
it's essential to the authoritarian
imagination that everyone those prose
those Epsilon's of whom will speaks are
focused on the threatening other and not
on the powers-that-be not on the
structure of power and that's only
possible or well understood if the past
itself becomes meaningless
we can only constantly move the object
of our rage and our fear effectively if
we no longer have a regular and reliable
grasp on our own history at one moment
in 1984 you'll recall Winston is sure
that he's seen one potent piece of
newspaper that has a photograph of three
purged inner party members who are now
non persons now never existed at all and
he's convinced that if he can only share
this information this simple fact that
there was a past things actually
happened in one way and not in any way
that authority decrees if he can hold on
to that then he can hold on to his
sanity and to his sense of his inner
self but even with his beloved Julia the
woman for whom he has risked everything
he can't convey how essential it it is
to have a secure grasp of what happened
once
sometimes he talked to her of the
records department and the impudent
forgeries that he committed there such
things did not appear to horrify her she
did not feel the abyss opening beneath
her feet
the thought of lies becoming truths he
told her the story of Jones Aaronson and
Rutherford and her momenta slip of paper
which he had once held between his
fingers did not make much impression on
her at first indeed she failed to grasp
the point of the story were they friends
of yours she said no I never knew them
they were inner party members besides
they were far older men than I was they
belonged to the old days before the
Revolution I barely knew them by sight
then what was there to worry about
people are being killed off all the time
aren't they he tried to make her
understand this was an exceptional case
it wasn't just a question of somebody
being killed do you realize that the
past starting from yesterday has been
actually abolished if it survives
anywhere it's in a few solid object with
no words attached to them like that lump
of glass there already we know almost
literally nothing about the revolution
and the years before the revolution
every record has been destroyed or
falsified every book has been rewritten
every picture has been repainted every
statue and Street and building has been
renamed every date has been altered and
that process is continuing day by day
and minute by minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party is always right I know of course
that the past is falsified but it would
never be possible for me to prove it
even when I did the falsification myself
after the thing is done no evidence ever
remains the only evidence is inside my
own mind and I don't know with any
certainty that any other human being
shares my memories just in that one
instance in my whole life I did possess
actual concrete evidence after the event
years after it and what good was that it
was no good because I threw it away a
few minutes later but if the same thing
happened today I should keep it
well I wouldn't sir Julia I'm quite
ready to take risks but only for
something worthwhile not bits of old
newspaper what could you have done with
it even if you had kept it not much
perhaps but it was evidence it might
have planted a few doubts here and there
supposing that I dared to show it to
anybody I don't imagine that we can
alter anything in our own lifetime but
one can imagine little knots of
resistance springing up here and there
small groups of people banding
themselves together and gradually
growing and even leaving a few records
behind so that the next generations can
carry on where we leave off I'm not
interested in the next generation dear
I'm interested in us you're only a rebel
from the waist downwards
[Applause]
think of how the wave of autocracy the
wave of renewed authoritarianism that's
sweeping through the world right now how
it reasons think about how fragile our
grasp on the past becomes in France the
country where I lived for many years the
National Front goes about making 1940
hard to recuperate in its reality in
Russia we've seen how putinism makes the
actuality of the hundred years between
the Revolution and today always up in
the air again loses its essential hold
on what really happened in our own
country in the United States of America
things that happened a mere eight months
ago the number of people who we're at
Trump's and oration the number of votes
cast for Hillary Clinton or for Trump
are thrown up in the air and we're told
that they're undecidable we're told that
there are two sides to a story in which
in reality there is only one side but
our ability to grasp and assert that
truth is as fragile as Winston's piece
of newspaper with the three inner party
members on it another way in which the
totalitarian mind works and is working
now is through a simple brute power will
is absolutely right to point to what's
happening in the Congo or in Africa or
everywhere else not through Huxley's
imagined pursuit of pleasure and
elimination of strife and difficulty all
the Shakespearean emotions know the
world is ruled now as it was in Orwell's
time by brute power because brute power
alone can make us change our simple
grasp of arithmetic
how can you stop people remembering
things cried Winston momentarily
forgetting the dial it is involuntary it
is outside oneself how can you control
memory you've not controlled mine
O'Brien's manner grew Stern again he
laid his hand on the dial on the
contrary he said you have not controlled
it that is what has brought you here you
are here because you have failed in
humility in self-discipline you will not
make the act of submission which is the
price of sanity you preferred to be a
lunatic a minority of one only the
disciplined mind can see reality Winston
you believe that reality is something
objective external existing in its own
right you also believe that the nature
of reality is self evident when you
delude yourself into thinking that you
see something you assume that everyone
else sees the same thing as you but I
tell you Winston that everyone else sees
the same thing that reality is not
external reality exists in the human
mind and nowhere else not in the
individual mind which can make mistakes
and in any case soon perishes only in
the mind of the party which is
collective and immortal whatever the
party holds to be the truth is true it
is impossible to see reality except by
looking through the eyes of the party
that is the fact you have got to read
learn Winston it needs an act of self
destruction an effort of the will you
must humble yourself before you can
become sane he paused for a few moments
as though to allow what he had been
saying to sink in you remember he went
on writing in your diary freedom is the
freedom to say that two plus two make
four
yes said Winston O'Brien held up his
left hand its back towards Winston with
the thumb hidden and the four fingers
extended how many fingers am i holding
up Winston
four and if the party says that it is
not four but five then how many four the
word ended in a gasp of pain the needle
of the dial had shot up 255 the sweat
had sprung out all over Winston's body
the air tore into his lungs and issued
again deep groans which even by
clenching his teeth he could not stop
O'Brien watched him the four fingers
still extended he drew back the lever
this time the pain was only slightly
eased how many fingers Winston for the
needle went up to 60 how many fingers
Winston for four what else can I say for
the needle must have risen again but he
didn't look at it the heavy Stern face
and the four fingers filled his vision
the finger stood up before his eyes like
pillars enormous blurry and seemed to
vibrate but unmistakably for how many
fingers Winston for stop it stop it how
can you go on for four how many fingers
Winston I five five no Winston that is
no use you are lying
you still think there are four how many
fingers please for five for anything you
like only stop it stop the pain abruptly
he was sitting up with O'Brien's arm
round his shoulders he had perhaps lost
consciousness for a few seconds the
bonds that held his body down were
loosened he felt very cold he was
shaking uncontrollably his teeth were
chattering the tears were rolling down
his cheeks for a moment he clung to her
Brian like a baby
curiously comforted by the heavy arm
around his shoulders he had the feeling
that O'Brien was his protector that the
pain was something that came from
outside from some other source and that
it was O'Brien who had save him from it
you are a slow learner Winston said
O'Brien gently how can I help it he
blubbered how how can I help seeing what
is in front of my eyes two and two are
four sometimes Winston sometimes they
are five sometimes they are three
sometimes they are all of them at once
you must try harder it is not easy to
become sane
[Applause]
all over the world scenes like the one
that we just dramatized from Orwell are
taking place
that's how powers still asserts itself
yes we're lucky here tonight in this
London meeting room we're not likely to
be taken to room 101 tonight but all
around the world far more people are
being hauled into the rooms 101 of
autocracies and tyrannies of all kinds
than are being eject injected with an
elating soma that brings them up and one
last thing that Orwell understood
prescient Lee prophetically even beyond
his understanding of the nature of the
Stalinist tyranny he understood that
finally power is there for its own sake
and if there is a single chilling truth
about the 21st century is that we've
seen in putinism in Russia in trumpism
in America an ideology of
authoritarianism that no longer relies
even even on the vision even on the lie
of an improved world
it simply asserts itself as brutal
domination for domination sake that was
stupid
Winston stupid he said you should know
better than to say a thing like that he
pulled the lever back and continued now
I will tell you the answer to my
question it is this the party seeks
power entirely for its own sake we are
not interested in the good of others we
are interested solely in power not
wealth or luxury long life or happiness
only power pure power what pure power
means you will understand presently we
are different all the oligarchies of the
past in that we know what we are doing
all the others even
who resembled ourselves with cowards and
hypocrites the German Nazis and the
Russian communists came very close to us
in their methods but they never had the
courage to recognize their own motives
they pretended perhaps they even
believed that they had seized power
unwillingly and for a limited time and
the just round the corner their lair
paradise where human beings would be
free and equal we are not like that we
know that no one ever sees his power
with the intention of relinquishing it
power is not a means it is an end does
not establish a dictatorship in order to
safeguard a revolution when establishes
makes the revolution in order to
establish the dictatorship the object of
persecution is persecution the object of
torture is torture the object of power
is power
now do you begin to understand me
O'Brien leaned over him deliberately
bringing the warm face nearer power over
matter external reality is you would
call it there's not important
already our control over matter is
absolute the real power the power we
have to fight for night and day is not
power over things but over men he paused
and for a moment assumed again his air
of a schoolmaster questioning a
promising pupil how does one man assert
his power over another Winston Winston
thought by making him suffer he said
exactly by making him suffer obedience
is not enough
unless he is suffering how can you be
sure that he is obeying your will and
not his own power is in inflicting pain
and humiliation power is in caring human
minds to pieces and putting them
together again in new shapes of your own
choosing you begin to see then what kind
of a world we have created it is the
exact opposite of the stupid hedonistic
utopias of the old reformers imagined
the world of fear and treachery is
torment a world of trampling and being
trampled upon the world which will grow
not less but more merciless as it
refines itself progress in our world
will be progressed towards more pain the
old civilizations claimed that they were
founded on love nor justice ours is
founded upon hatred in our world there
will be no emotions except fear rage
triumph and self abasement everything
else we shall destroy everything
thank you ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
would that Huxley's vision which will
has so ably advocated for tonight
where's the truth of our time would that
the blind pursuit of material pleasure
was leading us to a hedonistic utopia
where pain and strife were no longer
available to us I ask you if that's the
world you see at this moment when a wave
of authoritarianism is sweeping across
the planet or if you do not see as I do
as an emissary from a country where is
in the midst of happening a new ideology
in which power and pain perpetuate
themselves for their own sake over and
over and I ask you of that is not the
core of Orwell's vision and if it is not
the horrifying truth of our time thank
you so much
[Applause]
thank you but thanks thanks to both our
speakers for such powerful advocacy of
these two remarkable novels as you know
before you came in you did have a little
vote a straw poll which gave us some
sense of the room and let me just tell
you now the outcome of that vote which
obviously may have moved through the
power and rhetoric we've just heard
before as you came in the number of
people who voted for brave new world was
the most pre siient novel of our time
was 35 percent the number who cast their
votes for 1984 was 41 percent and there
were 24% who would don't knows so that's
how things stood before we all came in
we're gonna have just a very short
discussion here but and then we're gonna
open it up for questions in a few
minutes time there'll be a chance to
cast your votes and new I want to put to
each of you in a way that I mean you
made so many strong points but one of
your strongest points each to to each
side and first we'll starting with you
will so if you're a writer you know and
value the importance of language the
point Adam Gopnik made was that how
central the control of language is in
1984 and surely a sign of its resonance
in our own time is the fact that this
novel 70 years on has shaped so much of
our vocabulary today so to this day we
still speak of thoughtcrime room 101
bigbrother doublethink non-person the
list goes on
surely that itself shows you the power
of this novel and how prescient and
resolute it is for our time yes and what
do we use room 101 and Big Brother to
refer to television programs I just
asked you you know Big Brother stands at
the center of 1984 Ford stands at the
center of brave new world and Ford
symbolizes all of the multinational
corporations who are smuggling away and
not declaring their tax not paying their
taxes and who was selling to you yeah
it's not a pleasurable you
Opia for most of the world but I ask you
are you gonna believe this hole and in
the next few weeks indulge in collective
hate ceremonies or are you going to have
a drugged up solidarity ceremony in
which you collectively spunk off
millions of pounds on consumer goods you
don't need I think probably the latter
and in answer to Adams point about the
control of language and Twitter he's got
it completely wrong
that's not language language isn't being
impoverished
that's a mediatised discourse and the
commoditized discourse and again it's a
function of Huxley's vision of a world
dominated by technology
thank you the the chance to cast your
vote new is already happening real quick
on the uptake here and so the way you're
gonna vote as you hear these closing
arguments he's using your ballot paper
here there's a very convenient little
perforated edge just break that apart
and put in to the ballot box whichever
novel you feel is the one more prescient
for our time but haven't got me you can
come back on that point there about
language but I also wanted to put you
that the elements of our world that will
self emphasized in his opening
presentation form such a part of our
world from consumerism antidepressant
drugs pornography contraception genetic
engineering there were so many
technological innovations that albeit
sitting in 1931 Aldous Huxley did seem
to preempt he may not have given us
quite the vocabulary the 1984 did but he
does seem to anticipate so many of the
things that shape our world there's no
question brave new world is an
extraordinary prescient and and in every
way remarkable novel as I said at the
beginning of my remarks tonight
the striking thing is it as recently as
the millennium I would have taken wills
side and I would have agreed with him I
would have I would have grabbed that I
think that as a great man said once when
the world changes are when the facts
change our views have to change and it
seems to me that the facts have changed
in the most dramatic possible way in the
last decade the last five years
the last one year
and have reminded us that exactly the
world in which we thought we were living
this matrix of pleasure in hedonism is
not the world in which we are actually
living the world in which we're actually
living is one in which power is
asserting itself in the most brutal
imaginable way everywhere from Moscow to
New York City and the conditions of the
world have changed and our understanding
of literature has to change with it
to your point which i think is a
reasonable one that Twitter far from
being news speak in fact is an extension
of Technology and is Huxley and
commoditization is true what no one
foresaw properly when Twitter first came
forward is that the finest tweeters
would be would be authoritarian tyrants
who everyone thought it would be a great
cocktail party in which all would share
and it turns out to be a big fascist
meeting in which one big boss tweets out
his rule his assertion of the day
including wildly false and fake
assertions I feel that's inherent in the
medium because it only allows for brief
assertion rather than elaborate and
complex how do you come how do you come
back at a an authoritarian assertion all
you can have as I said is a counter
assertion but assertion and counter
assertion are not the means are not the
Chi
argument and democracy depends Liberty
depends on argument well yes but I mean
the real thought police of course are
already in your pocket and it's it's
your Google search engine that is also
adverting these are transnational
phenomena I don't doubt we're in a
period of right-wing and nationalist
reverse ISM but but you know what all
well dwells on Adams so lovingly in his
depiction of airstrip one and Oceania is
is the mechanisms of the party and the
totalitarian the raw totalitarianism
expressed very much using the methods of
the the great totalitarian regimes of
the past what he doesn't foresee at all
is the creeping totalitarianism of
consumerism and mass consumption and
mass advertising he just doesn't get
there or understand that at all and
while I absolutely accept your argument
I thought you made it very well as a
clarion call for us to resist
authoritarian and potentially though not
actually yet totalitarian regimes that's
true what I'm more concerned about is
the creeping one state totalitarianism
that is conditioning you through those
electric pulses and that's really clear
what about Adam governings point about
the wall on the past that Putin and now
are engaged in a war on fact yes even
about the size of the inaugural crowds
that feels very O'Bryant if it's
happening now it does feel very O'Brien
and I I agree to some extent but you
have to see that it works in lockstep
curiously with a with a weird
environment in which actually you can
say anything you want
but guess what no one's listening all
right let's get some responses from our
audience we've time is very much
marching on but that we've got somebody
there we're going to take party two or
three we'll bring it back here yeah
we'll go to number four next number one
yeah I'm dr. Anthony fry I'm a
neuropsychiatrist I know Zack Posner but
I am an ordinary practicing doc and I'm
not a celebrity so for God's sake try
and realized that unfamous people are
also have things to say very quickly
there's a clear line from being smacked
out on the prime minister's jet to
orders Huxley ordering his LSD as he was
dying and I believe that the future is
in brave new world we've seen nothing
certainly two billion people follow
Facebook but wait to the Google glasses
move one step further and there is a
digital wide electrode in your brain
people Huxley saw as new humans are
nearly with us thank you predict twenty
years to go thank you very much yeah
let's go for a question there yep
gopnik was using the words
authoritarianism and totalitarianism
interchangeably and both self I think
was somewhat terrifying that but they
are actually quite different things
totalitarian state that we know in
today's well just North Korea Russia and
the United States authoritarian say it's
all becoming increasingly Serb if they
are not territory
Hannah Arendt who was also an incredible
commentator on what was going on and
seeing into the future wrote about that
I think have you got a question for our
I think I'm allowed to make a comment
well we certainly heard the comment it
was a question I was after third
question yep do you believe the
difference is that we haven't become a
we are not to terrorism we are not this
one entity that you can control but
every there are groups of different
people and therefore to group us as in
blocks is is where brave new world it
separates us from 1984 where communism
has failed
Nazism has failed all these one person
one value one way has failed brave new
world says that there are far more ways
of manipulating individual groups as a
whole thank you let's let's bring some
of these Punk's out I'll come to they
forget if we've time allows so to you
Adam first this point about the
distinction between that yes our world
certain has authoritarianism but 1984
was talking about totalitarianism and
there with the exception the question
who says Newton North Korea that's not
our world well I have dared to praise or
well and I will admit that I have in the
past dared to criticize Hannah Arendt as
well
I think that that distinction
distinction the Chitra and others have
drawn is made into schematic away the
truth is is that every authoritarian
state is a totalitarian state waiting to
happen in totalitarian states very often
devolve very quickly back into being
authoritarian states history of the
Soviet Union is a good example of that
and so try saying that we're merely
living in an authoritarian state and not
yet a totalitarian one is a bit like
saying we have the first signs of you
banach plague but it hasn't fully
developed throughout our system it's bad
enough to be in an authoritarian
condition because it tends to evolve in
that direction thank you and to you was
of this this question it was put over
there about the difference between
people and whether or not we know one of
the reasons why communism and other
things failed as they didn't recognize
the inherent pluralism of people and
perhaps brave new world with it's very
rigid car system doesn't reflect the
diversity of human beings well I mean I
think the interesting thing about let's
get this straight I think the the
penetrating quality of heart sees vision
was yeah you know the the technology he
advanced most clearly in in brave new
world was genetic engineering but what
does it give you it gives you the
equivalent with epsilon semi morons and
Delta's of the kind of automation that's
doing you out of jobs now and what it
also in my view kind of slightly
reflects is the way the internet and the
web in conjunction with multinational
corporations and advertisers can treat
people as groups for the purposes of
selling and therefore pacifying them so
that is you know that that to me is very
redolent of the one-state world and and
if I could just comment on the point
about totalitarian versus authoritarian
everything Adam says is true and we
should certainly guard against a new
totalitarianism but it's not going to
take the form of kind of everybody
belonging to a party and everybody the
form of totalitarianism that we should
be on guard against has already happened
it's already happened we already have a
totalitarian one state culture and
and you all know it so I really think
I've won well we'll know for sure very
soon let's go take another couple of
questions if we can squeeze them in
thank you very much for this debate I
was rather surprised - surprised - your
discussion of 1984 without mentioning of
government surveillance 1918 for is big
metaphor for government surveillance
around the world and I think this is
where all will falls short because we're
not surrounded by Big Brother we're
surrounded by big brothers and sisters
and cousins and neighbors lofty your
thoughts on this Thank You Christian
let's hear from somebody there yeah hi
yeah well we've presented it very much
as one versus the other
in terms of brave new world versus 1984
but is it not more the case where you
know what sorry the question is are they
necessarily mutually exclusive you've
anticipated of course my very feel-good
closing remarks you've you're getting
ahead of ourselves but that's a very
helpful contribution and one which I
will return to do we have one more
question hovering I just want to build
on that last question I asked you if we
were to broaden this out beyond our sort
of Western current dystopian fears and I
got a lot of that coming from from
yourself Adam as well understandably
and look at China as an example of a
potential future a major power and very
much on the rise and I wonder whether
we're seeing something there where you
might see a 1984 type vision evolving in
quite an interesting and rapid way
towards some of the content of a brave
brave new world because that is that you
know that the China or such forces of
the future are not going to be and as we
might have imagined previously everyone
is pushing you to together
maybe you've notices they want this to
end in harmony and unity let's have a
final question here and then we'll have
closing remarks yeah okay brave new
world and the issue of conditioning when
you look at issues especially in the
states around the Flint water crisis or
austerity measures that roll back
environmental protections specifically
around lead paint or suitability of
children's housing which we know has a
distinct impact on intelligence are we
in some ways
instituting the conditioning that brave
new world suggested okay thank you
well it's 40 I'm gonna reverse the order
a little bit here surely this point that
the questioner made about surveillance
is indeed one of the strongest cases for
1984's
prescient the notion that there is CCTV
everywhere we're constantly surveilled
all well got that right yeah but who are
we being surveilled by I mean the thing
is the back door that was opened by the
NSA in cahoots with Google Microsoft etc
is if you think about it much more to do
with consumption than it is to do with
surveillance and actually the people in
the NSA I mean sociologists call it
professional closure their surveillance
is really only a concomitant of that
commercial surveillance so yeah I think
Orwell got it right in some ways that we
were going to live if you like in our in
a world in which we were permanently
surveyed but I would argue that the
purposes of that surveillance is more to
make us good little tractable consumers
than it is to confirm our ideological
purity and also if I could just say the
gentleman he mentioned China here I
thought it's very significant Adam that
you didn't talk about China and I'd
argue that you didn't mention China in
your list of authoritarian regimes
precisely because of what you're saying
it's mutating into brave new world why
don't you come back with that and then
we're gonna have closing remarks all
right China I failed to mention some
more from a slip of the mind than from
any particular strategic purpose I will
say China does seem to be mutating from
Orwell to Huxley without going through
Jefferson and Mill along the way first
it seems to me in fact China is a very
frightening example of how it's possible
it seems to have a free market without
civil freedoms at all I find that
frightening rather than reassuring and
let me say where I think will and I have
a genuine and profound disagreement is
that consumerist society with all of its
absurdities oppressions and homogenize a
ssin of sensibility turns out to be a
very small form of oppression compared
to autocratic Society
with a few little trainers in it and
then sweatshop in the third world open
absolutely the problem is that when we
have the sweatshop in the third world
extended into increasingly into the
first world that's what we're seeing as
as the way and I am here to say as an a
radicalized American that however bad
you think the Empire the Internet is the
Empire of the oligarchs is worse
very good we've got 30 seconds left for
each of you before I reveal the result
of tonight's vote 30 seconds of absolute
closing distilled to sentence argument
for your case for brave new world and
then you for 1984 why don't you stop I'm
not gonna make a case for the knoll I've
done that already I'll make a case for
aldous huxley a man who battled
blindness all his life who went to to
live in the States and suffer too
terrible misfortunes that mean he
doesn't have the place that all well has
in our national consciousness one is all
his books and personal papers were
destroyed in a fire two years before he
died so we've never had been able to
have the kind of love in on Huxley that
goes on with all well so I think he
would have a much more salient place in
our culture without that fact the second
kicking in in the poor man's arse as he
departed life was he died on the same
day as President Kennedy was
assassinated and so nobody ever paid any
attention to it so let's recover poor
old Aldous not that we want to diss
George but Aldous needs to be brought
okay Clayton thank you closing a closing
couple of sentences from you Adam got me
it reminds me of when the great Groucho
Marx died in the same day as Elvis and
no one was was around to notice
let me say something about or Willman I
have never been in the past a uncritical
Orwell fan many things that Orwell
thought were either wrong or as I wrote
once how can we praise the clarity of
someone with whom everyone agrees that
this seems to me true nonetheless as I
tried to say tonight Orwell had enormous
clarity of mind and with an enormous
lucidity of thought and he captured
something that's utterly essential in
that will we unfortunately are living
with now and that is that the appetite
for power in the modern world
is not an appetite is not a warped
appetite to give us all pleasure as
Huxley believed that the appetite for
power is in itself a predatory drive
that governs the world that's essential
and I have learned from it thank you
thank you
my unscientific suspicion is that quite
a lot of people in this room share the
sentiment I think was voiced in a couple
of questions which is to say that both
of these books have tremendous things to
say and value and insight into the world
we live in now nevertheless he has been
a competition and a debate so you want
to hear the result before you came in
the vote was votes for brave new world
35% for 1984 41% and nearly a quarter
24% of you were undecided well since
then there is only now 1% a view that
who are undecided and I can reveal that
34% still believe 1984 is the book that
speaks to us but a stunning 65 percent
have voted for brave new world a swing
of 19% it means the winner of tonight's
debate is brave new world by Aldous
Huxley and it's advocate will self but
I'm sure you're going to want to thank
not only will self but also of course
Adam Gopnik
and our tremendous car star performers
Simon Callow
tuppence Middleton George Blagdon and
Orlando seal thanks all of you good
night
[Applause]